hey everyone it's nurse Sarah with
registered nurse rn.com and in this
video I'm going to show you how to set
up your Foley catheter tray so we're
just going to bring It Up Lift these
sides up and then pull the tray out and
then put this back to the side so I'm
going to take this off and then look at
what's in our kit here we have cleanser
to cleanse the Perry urethral area first
we will do this first before we do
anything else and then it has directions
to use some other little education
pieces in a different language Spanish
and then these are stickers that we're
going to be putting in the chart and on
our drainage tubing we'll put that to
the side so let's prep for this so I've
washed my hands and I've done clean
gloves so I'm going to take this out in
here
and in this little package we have the
soap towelettes to clean the area and
then afterwards we have this to wash our
hands with so I'll provide periathral
care then golf gloves and perform hand
hygiene now we're ready to set up the
supply so again when you're setting up
your supplies you want to make sure that
you are positioned where your
non-dominant hand is going to be closest
to the patient because this hand is
going to be used to help you open the
labia during insertion so we're going to
take our wrap kit we can touch this part
right now because this is the shiny side
and the shiny side is going to go on
your surrounding surfaces remember shiny
go in surrounding surfaces it's not
sterile so we can touch this so we're
going to move this and we're going to
orient it toward the insertion side so
it's going to go on the bed and in
between the patient's legs now we're
going to open our CSR wrap so you have
to do this in a specific way because we
don't want to reach over our kit with
our hand which could contaminate the
seraphile field so what we're going to
do is we're going to peel this to open
it
get that part off
and we are going to take this top tab
off and pull it this way away from us
you have one inch on this dull side that
is considered non-sterile so it's like a
one inch border that you could touch or
you could just grab the shiny side and
pull it's whatever you prefer so pull
that then we're going to do our side
tabs
so remember you have one inch
roll like that and then we're going to
do the inside one and pull it like that
next what we're going to do is we're
going to Dawn the sterile gloves now you
never want to turn your back on this
whole sterile field because if you do
you're going to have to start over once
the sterile gloves are on you can't
touch anything outside of the kit you
can only touch things that are inside
the kit because everything is sterile so
we're going to Dawn these sterile gloves
outside the sterile field so now let's
open up our gloves turning the package
around and always read the little words
on the packaging to help you Orient it
we're going to take the tabs stick our
hands underneath the tabs
and pull it out
you have about a one to two inch border
to work with so that paper folds out
nice and neat so you can get in there to
those gloves I'm going to glove my
dominant hands so I'm taking my
non-dominant grab this cuff and I'm
going to
slide it over like so
okay this is now sterile we cannot touch
anything outside of our sterile field
and then I'm going to go under this cuff
right here
to glove my dominant hand
foreign
now we're going to drape the patient and
we're going to be placing two different
pads the first pad we're going to place
is called the under pad and the reason
we're placing all of these pads is
because we want to extend our sterile
field so we are going to get the under
pad it should be the top pad and we're
just going to grab it here I want you to
see both of these sides we have a shiny
side and we have a dull side remember
the shiny side is the shot the side
that's going to go on the surrounding
surfaces so it's going to go down so
we're going to place this under the
patient's bottom then we're going to
take our finished straighter drape and
put it over the patient's genitals it's
going to have a hole that gives us an
area to work so we're going to grab this
and let this unfold itself and then
we're going to take the shiny side put
it on the patient and again being
careful as we drape now we're going to
set up our kit and this kit is really
cool because it labels every step for us
so here we have our Foley with the
drainage bag we have the securement
device a stat lock device that we're
going to be applying later so the very
first thing that we need to do is we
need to open the add-on so we're going
to open this iodine and we are going to
put it on these swabs right here step
two is poor swap pour on the swabs so
tear here
and then we're going to just put it on
our swabs right here because this is
what's going to be used to clean our
labia and we're going to discard this
then what we're going to do is we're
going to attach the water syringe so
we're going to just connect it to this
port here we no longer test the balloon
prior to insertion because doing that
they have found changes the shape of
that balloon prior to inserting it up
through the urethra when we change the
shape it could damage the urethra which
could cause a urinary tract infection
and we don't want to do that so here's
our water syringe and this Foley that we
are dealing with it tells us it's a 14
French and to inflate with 10 mL of
water you always want to pay attention
to that because that's really important
whenever you go to remove it so this is
the port that we're going to be
instilling that water in whenever we're
ready to after insertion but right now
we're just going to connect it there and
set it aside because we're going to be
using that when we're done inserting the
next what we're going to do is we are
going to dispense the lubricant here so
we can lubricate the tip of our catheter
prior to insertion this is really
important so this is a comfortable
procedure as much as it can be for your
patient so we're going to take that
we're going to just put it in here
and discard this then we are going to
remove the catheter very carefully
through from this plastic sheathing and
you definitely want to let it coil like
that because if you just pull this thing
out it's going to go flying off your
sterile field and then you're going to
startle over so for females we want to
lubricate at least two inches of this
tip so we're going to put it in there
Okay so we've prepped everything that we
need now next up we here in a moment are
going to clean the area prior to
insertion but also in some kits you have
a urine sample collection
cup if you needed that with some
labeling and then you have your drainage
bag you always want to make sure your
kit came with a drainage bag because if
not you would need that and this one did